それでもみるみるうちに私たちの体が新しく生まれ変わっているんです
そこでこのブロック入れ替えるのはもう子供だから
けっかく例えばしっかりと作った何か形が置いておいて
じゃああなたはちゃんと一分単位でもいいし
まあ三十秒でもいいし
一つ一つ入れ替えてくださいって言ったら
まあ三十分経ってみたらあれガタガタなんですね
どうせ子供がするものだからほとんどいい加減なんですね
そんなもので 我々の DNA の老化にしたっても
まあただ入れ替えるだけで
だから老化して壊れて
力がなくなっちゃって
壊れて死んでしまっちゃうんですね
それは避けられないんです
まあアーハラというのはそういうもので
今説明したのはこの物質の働きで
で 仏教の場合はアーハラと四種類ですからね
アーハラが四つあるんですね
その四つの中で一つは物質ですね
人間 この取って食べる物質
全て一つ で また三つはこの心の食べ物なんですね
それはこの この三つなんですね
ファッサ チェータナ ヴィンニャーナ
ファッサっていうのは
この 心はなぜ生き生き続く
生き続くんですかね やっぱり変化し続くんですからね
心はなぜ変化し続くことはできますかと
例えば噴水の場合も なぜ噴水があるかというと
ずっとそこに何かつけてあげないと噴水というのは成り立ちませんし
蛍光灯の光にしたっても
なんで蛍光灯は光っているんですか？と
ずっとこの流れ通してエネルギーを上げないと蛍光灯は光るわけじゃないんですね
そういうふうに我々はずっと物事を認識しているんですね
その認識するためには
ファッサというコンタクト
触れること必要なんで
何に触れるかというと
外界に触れること 目には光触れる
耳には音を触れる 体には熱さ寒さが触れる
鼻には香りが触れる 舌に味が触れる
それで認識しちゃうんですね
そこで頭の中にはいろんなアイデアやら概念やら
いろんなものを触れちゃう
それで思考が回転しちゃう
やっぱり何か触れなきゃ心が現れません
心は生まれません ですから
この触れることは瞬間でも止まりません
いくらでもあるんです
じゃあ目を開けておけば
この見えるものは消える時もありますか？いつでもあります
消えません だから心は止まることはないんですね
そこでみんな思うかもしれませんが
光があるんだから見える
じゃあ光がなくなっちゃったら終わりでしょうにと
そうすると暗闇が見えるんですよ
これ触れるんです 残念ですけど
だからこの視覚っていうものは
もう目を開けてるたび場合はずっと働くんですね
この瞑想する時で いろんなくだらないもの見えたり
なぜするんですか？って落ち着いてないんですね
自分の視覚 脳の中の視覚機能を停止しないんですね
そういう人々は瞑想するといろんなものを見る
そこでまあ私には効きませんだからね
まあそれで効かない方がいいんです
で いろんなところでいろいろ自分たちで宗教的哲学的に解釈するんですね
やっぱりそこはこういうことではなく
ああいうことで これはクンダリニではないかとかね
これはチャクラではないかとか
私に言えるのは あなたね
ちょっと落ち着いてこの視覚の働き
止まり止まってみなさいと
簡単に脳の中で視覚の機能止まることできますよ
シャッターを切る方法を分かってないだけ
音も聴覚 簡単に集中できます
そうやって聴覚と視覚をスイッチオフして瞑想してみれば
この体から入ってくる触覚というんですかね
コンタクトですね そういうチャネルをオフになっちゃうと体が無いと感じちゃうんです
これを瞑想をずっとやると
もうたまたまそういう出来事が起こるんですね
だからしっかりした訓練じゃないんだから
ちゃんとあるチャネルに絞ってやるものじゃないんだから
適当にいろんな現象が起きたり消えたりする
ヴィパッサナーではある一つのチャネルに集中してやらせようとしないので
そうするともう妄想で誤解で終わっちゃうんですね
ただ集中して見ることだけしなさいと
どんなのでもいいんだから
そうすると時々 時々聴覚だけ働く
そうすると今だかって聞いたことがない音を認識したりする
時々視覚だけ働く その時はもう一度も聞いた見たことがないものを見えたりする
時々体から入ってくるこの触覚のチャネルが消えたりする
それで自分の体が消えたような感じたりする
そうやっていろんなことを出来事起こるんですね
その出来事には特別な意味があるわけじゃなくて
そういう実験をしながら
データからあなたは何を発見するかっていうことがポイントなんです
データには大した意味がないんです
うん そこで 触というのはそういうことで
いつでも我々の体にものを触れる
それによって頭が回転する
それで目がと体が完全にストップしたっても
心が自分で自動的に回転する
それでということで 論理的に我々は心にもものが触れると言うんです
同じ言葉でまとめなきゃいけませんだから
ですから 例えば過去のことやら将来のこと
何でもいいんです あるものもないものも何か概念ですね
だから法と言うんです
その場合は 何か心に触れて
すごい声がそれについて思考が働いて動いてしまうんです
回転してしまうんです
だから心に触れるものには何か実体性ないんだから
一番ややこしいんですよ
例えば目を開けて こちらのあれはバラの花です
花でそれで終わる人が安全ですよ
いろんなものを考える人は本当に大変なんです
もう治らないんです なぜか
かというと 目はコントロールされているでしょ
光がなければ ある距離でなければ見えません
バラの花を見て そこに蛇が見える人っていうのはほとんどない
これは花ではなくて蛇だよと
ほとんどない もし人がいたならば
私たちはすぐ知ってるんです
この人はちょっと問題あるんだから
ちょっとお医者さんに見てもらおうと
それはそんなに社会的な問題にはなりません
だから見えた 聞こえた
そこだけ止まる人は でも頭だけで回転する場合は
頭ではあるものもないものも何でも認識できるんですね
コントロールないんです
コントロールないことは本当は悪いことなんですけど
世の中の人はいいことにしているんですね
だからもう本やらいろんなものを書くはあるはある
いろんなことを考えて考えて考える
この間どこかで例に出しちゃったんだけど
あの古い池屋ですか あの川に飛び込むと店の音っていう俳句があるんですね
だからそれいまだにありがたく我々は考えている俳句なんですけども
人間の心っていうのはもう余計なことを勝手に考えたりするんだから
もうそんなことを考えるんだったら
それ書いた場相は何を考えてさっぱりわからないでしょうに
だから俳句はなぜ成り立つかというと
あなた勝手に考えてくださいと
ということなんです そうでなきゃ俳句っていうのはもう別につまらないんです
私たちには妄想する能力なければ面白くも何もないんです
それだったらそれよりは
例えばシェイクスピアとか
そういう人々が書いてる歌っていうのはしっかりしているんです
はっきりと決まってるんです
それ以上考えることできません
そちらで書いているんです
これやと 俳句の場合はそうじゃないんです
こういうことを言ってるんだっていうことは言わないんですね
それは俳句の作り方で
そこで何を使用しているかというと
それぞれの人が自由に感じること
だから自分の世界で感じるんですね
そこで私たちはそういうことで何を理解するかというと
心っていうのは自由じゃなくて
何て言いますか 暴走しているんです
場相の俳句を読む日本人とナイジェリアの黒人と同じですかね
あるいはエチオピアの
例えばイスラム教の誰かに
あるいはパレスチナ人一人にこの歌を読んでみてくださいと
読むんでしょ その人は「これ素晴らしいですね」と言うかもしれません
でも あの砂漠の中で 四十度の暑いところで古い池屋と
何を考えるでしょうかね
そこでまあここは国際的に有名になったのはやっぱりこの英訳したんだからでしょうし
英訳した時 やっぱりイギリスとかね
そういう人々の イギリスだったらまあ Lake というとね
まあまた違うでしょうにね
イギリスの Lake と日本の池っていうのは
同じですかね 日本でもね
やっぱりまあ そこで見えるのは
この思考っていうのは事実と関係なく暴走するんだということだけ私は言いたい
別にもう他のことを言いたくはないんで
僕はもう仏教学問的に仏教科学的なものごとを見たいだけなんですね
我々にとっては大事なポイントは
この心っていうのは自分勝手に暴走しているということ
なぜ人々は精神的に病気になるんですかね
それは心が勝手に暴走しているんだからでしょう
例えば 厳しい父親に育てられたんだと
父親に殴られたんだと言って
そこで結果はバラバラさまさまでしょうに
あれは誰のせいですか
その人の心のせいであって
父親のせいじゃないんです
例えば母親に父親に捨てられて
捨て子になってどこかで育てられた子供がいて
それで自分には誰もないんだから
私は自分で全部やらなくちゃいけないと思って
勉強するなりにいろんな商売するなりにして
すごい大物になる可能性もあるし
犯罪者になる可能性もあるでしょう
そこに原因はどこにあるかというと
その二人の頭がどのように妄想したかということなんですね
そちらはコントロールないことは危険なんです
物事を考える場合は 例えば自分の父親がすごく厳しかったと言って威張る人もいるでしょうに
今の私がいるのは あの厳しい父親に育てられたんだからと
またもう一人 自分が自信がなくても
対人関係でものすごく弱くて
恐怖感で覆われて もう惨めな人生だったら
父親が厳しかったんだからという人もいるんですね
だから 正しく見れば 父親が悪かったわけでも良かったわけでもないんでしょうし
その人の心がどのように暴走したかということなんでしょうし
そこで父親のせいであの人生が暗くなったということは
我々それは問題だと それだけ直そうとしている
精神分析やらいろんなことをやったりして
哲学作る人の頭を直そうと誰もしないんですね
哲学の本を書く人な この人は病気だから
ちょっとカウンセリングしてあげましょうと思う人がいないんです
同じなんです どちらにも別で真実等何もあるわけじゃないんです
父親のおかげでもう厳しい父親に育てられたんだから
立派な人間になったぞということにも別に身体性事実はあるわけじゃないし
そちらのおかげで惨めな人間になったというところにもそれはないし
自分がすごい哲学 いろんなことを考えたりしてるんだというところで
そこで別にどったことがないんです
ただ 頭が勝手に暴走するだけ
でも暴走する時でも情報は必要なんですね
だからパレスチナ人が馬相の何でしたっけ
俳句を読む時も この感覚は違うかもしれませんよ
日本の今の学校で子供たちがそれを読む時の感覚と
パレスチナ人とまたイギリス人が読む時の感覚が違うかもしれません
そちらそちらで暴走する頭にはそれなりの情報がやっぱり必要なんです
それは心の発心 心の底なんですね
[背景音]ですからね
やっぱりこの人間というのは何の根拠もなしに
このアルマゲデンのアルマゲデドンですか
そういう概念やら世紀末とかね
これ二十一世紀 そこまで学問やら科学を発展しているのに
平気で世紀末とかなんとか言うんだから
ちょっと歴史勉強しちゃったら
今はね もう本当は二千二年か三年ですね
イエスが生まれてから六年差があるんだから
だから西暦一年と言ったのは
本当は西暦六年なんです
だからもうとっくに終わってるんです
そこでアーサーC クラークというこの小説
科学的な小説を書く人が言うのは
この このいわゆるこの数字
彼が科学者だからね 科学者で小説を書く人で
誰かが言うのは この二千年というのは本当は千九百九何で零年なかったんだから
一から数えたんだから
もっと先です まあそういうただの数字に引っかかるとかね
ただの昔の人々の物語に引っかかるとかね
現代我々妄想することと同じく
古い人々もいろんなことを妄想してストーリー作って書いちゃったんです
例えばこの世紀末の考え方は聖書にもあるんだけど
その当時の人々の世界観であって
それは頭の中 暴走することから生まれるんであって
頭六つ付いてる蛇が現れた時がね
もう世紀末なんですけど
見ただけでわかるでしょうに
まあ面白いストーリーと思って読もうとそれで終わっちゃいますからね
それに解釈をする 厳密に定義をする
どちらにでも事実的な根拠は全くないんですね
だからこのカッサというところの説明でいらないことを言いましたけど
この体に触れるものっていうのははっきりしていてコントロールされています
だから余計なことを考えることはできません
音が聞こえるという場合は条件があるんですよ
どんな音も聞こえるわけじゃないし
音のもういろいろ強弱はいろいろあるんです
だからコントロールされていますから
でも頭だけがコントロールない
一番危ないんです 考えることは
で それは栄養になりますと
だから触れることでなければ心は回転しないんです
そちらに問題っていうのは
触れる情報っていうのは一瞬でもなくならないんです
いつでもあるんです 限りなくある
無制限にあるんです そういうわけで
心に心はもう止まろうと思っても止まりません
じゃあ瞑想でもして心瞬間止まってみてください
止まりませんね このお釈迦様やらこのお釈迦様とか大阿羅漢の方々はこの滅尽定に入って心は止まるんだと
停止するんだという話があるんです
そのやり方っていうのは
この息をストップするんです
だからこれを訓練していけばできるんです
煩悩ある限りはできませんだけど
煩悩は全部消えちゃったら
どんな情報も受け取らないと
情報を受け取らなかったら栄養ないことだから
心は停止と 停止ということは心はないということなんです
この働きだから そこでまた
じゃあ情報を受け入れますということになったら
またそこで心が現れてきて回転し始める
そこにもアイデンティティがないんです
流れですから 我々はその同じだと思うだけのことでアイデンティティがない
だから皆様方の瞑想ではね
やっぱり視覚を取得する訓練やら聴覚を取得することやらね
そこら辺にやった方がよろしいと思いますけどね
そこでわざわざそんなことやろうとすると
それは欲望になる そこら辺でちょっと問題がありますけどね
はい えっと チェータナっていうのはあの業でも
業もチェータナであるし
チェータナっていうのは意志なんですね
何かやりたいという気持ち自体が
それでいろんなこと だから知りたいんだから知る
考えたいんだから考えている
妄想したいんだから妄想している
だからそのチェータナはいつでもあります
ヴィンナーナっていうのはもっと難しい
理解するヴィンナーナは心そのものなんです
心そのものは栄養になるんですね
次の心に だからAというものを認識する心が
真理 Bというものを認識する心の栄養になる
ということは Bという心がなぜ生まれたかというと A
という心が死んだんだから生まれたんです
だから一つの心が死ぬことは
次の心が生まれることなんです
それで輪廻というのはもう徹底的に成立しちゃうんです
死ぬことは生まれることの原因なんです
それがちょっとたとえとかなんとかでは何も言うことできませんだけど
例えばなぜ電気とかはわかりやすい
なぜこの電気が流れていくんですかというと
やっぱりここで光になって電気が死んじゃうんです
このエレクトロンのエネルギーが光になったら
もう光として他のものに吸収されちゃうんですね
もうない だからその代わりに新しいもの入っちゃうんです
まあ死ななかったらもうそれでストップなんですね
ですから あんまりそちらの例えは
例えとして言う例えはないんだよ
物質的なものから例え出さなくちゃいけないんだから
だからたまに浮かんだ例えというのは
細長い風船がありますね
それに空気を吹いて 一つのところをじっと押さえると他のところが膨らんじゃうんです
そこを押しちゃうと他のところが膨らんじゃう
なぜ膨らむ？ここが押されたんだからという
それだけの理由なんですね
でもそれで空気という同じ物体が動いてるんだから
それあまりいい例じゃないんです
そこで一つの心は死ぬと次の心が現れる
そういう働きから いわゆる仏教ではなんか余計な生死論とかね
書いてはいますけどね
[笑い]生は諦め 諦めるもの
なんていうんですか はっきり理解する人は死もはっきりしているんだと
生は知らない人は死は知らないんだ
死は知らない人は生は知りませんと
生は死であって 死は生であると
ただほおだとか まあ言葉並んだりしますけどね
なんとなく まあそういうのは文学でもあってね
まあ哲学とか何とかとか言えるかどうかちょっと別なんですけど
やっぱりもう論理的に科学的に喋った方が一番いいんです
もう文学的ではなくてね
だからまあもうもうそれでも因縁とかなんとかとかね
証明ではないんだけど
一応論理的になぜあるかっていうことぐらいはわかるだろうと思います
で 体の物質的な栄養は一つで
それは誰でもわかってる世界で
これは心の栄養 3つあります
心の栄養の体にも栄養はスーッとなければ体が死んじゃう
栄養は栄養なしに生きていられません
我々は 1 日 3回しか食べないかもしれませんだけど
それは正しい答えじゃないんです
細胞にはずっと栄養必要なんですね
脳にしたっても ほんの 2 3 秒でも酸素とかなくなっちゃったらもう倒れちゃいますから
大変なことなんです だからいかに栄養に支えられているかっていうことなんです
だから 1 秒でも細胞がもう動いてるでしょ
それもエネルギー必要なんです
エネルギーがなくなったらパチンとはじけて死んじゃうんです
それぐらいの脆い人生ですけどね
それでそれを誤解して
まあ 1 日 3回食べればいいやと
あるいはまた計算して人っていうのはもう断食したって 1週間ぐらいは大丈夫だと
私には 1分も大丈夫じゃないんだと
栄養がなくなった瞬間にもう壊れてガタガタと終わる
もう死んじゃうんです
例えば 1週間とか断食牛とか何とかやっても
それはもう毎日食べる
あるいは物質を取らないだけであって
もう体の中であっちこっち倉庫いっぱい栄養はね
倉庫で溜まってるんだからね
それは使ってるんです
だってこれ体の場合 心の場合も同じく
このパッサチェータ・ヴィンニャーナというのは 3つの栄養で心が生まれて死んで生まれて死んで生まれて死んでという
この流れが維持するんです
心が維持するんじゃなくて
流れが起きているんです
それはアーハーラ・パッチェというんです
なぜこれ原因ではないんです
こちらでなぜパッチェと言うかというと
さて この原因がアーハーラとして働いているんだということなんです
食として働いているんだと
条件は食の条件だと あの 5 分ぐらいちょっと休憩します
じゃあまた続き始まります
次の縁はインドリヤ・パッチェというんです
インドリヤっていうのは日本語で魂ですか
魂なんですけど なんか魂って言ったらわかりませんね
まあだから語根は分かりますね
原因非出身という インドリヤというのは英語で言えばこのfacultyという
まあ窓口みたいな意味なんですね
窓口とは例えばまあ色々